a fortnight's time we'll know who's to
become the next leader of the
conservative party and thus the new
prime minister of the united kingdom liz
truss and rishi sunak head to birmingham
today as they aim to put the manifestos
to tory members in the midlands so what
are the latest polls saying well in the
studio political commentator and former
president of yugo peter kellner it's
great to see you as always
thanks very much indeed for joining us
let's talk about the big lead for labour
to start with we had a yougov poll at
the weekend which showed a labor lead of
15 percentage points over the
conservatives the biggest nearly 10
years if that were the election results
labor would not just win they would have
a fairly comfortable overall majority
but whenever i see a single pole showing
a sudden change i say is this real or is
it a sampling fluke well we've had two
more poles since that yuga pole opinion
in sunday's observer and redfield and
wilson out this morning they disagree on
the raw figures but they agree
absolutely that labour's leaders shot up
by five or six points in the last week
or two so in three polls by different
companies slightly different methods all
agree on the direction of travel i think
we can take it as real okay so this hugo
poll at the weekend gave labour 43
points the conservatives um down on 28
and the lib dem was 11.
yeah um and remember at the last general
election the conservatives run 45
across britain so they're now down 17
points they've lost a third of their
support um
they are in i think very very deep
trouble i think when we talked to some
weeks ago i think i predicted that there
would be a honeymoon for the new tory
prime minister i'm not quite so sure
that'll happen the conservative
leadership campaign i think has done the
party quite a lot of harm and that's
part of what we're seeing here how did
you see that supporter on the program
just a few moments ago and he was saying
it isn't all over he's still uh in the
running is he
uh no
but right but he would say that wouldn't
he exactly that's what i thought talk to
me about labour's proposal for freezing
energy bills how's that looking
well here and you've got something quite
remarkable happening you've got the
labour's policy of freezing um bills
you've tested this amongst the general
public last week and found overwhelming
support for it with 69
saying it's a good idea just 13
saying it's a bad idea now you you do
occasionally get that sort of division
but i can't remember the last time on a
big controversial policy where leading
members of one political party are on
one side and the other party on the
other side i don't remember a figure
that's one-sided and i'm sure that's
part of the reason why labour's leader
has been going up
um yeah i mean that that proposition by
labour means that everybody will benefit
it's not just uh the worse off yeah it's
interesting you can make so many you can
make a lot of comments or criticisms
about it whether it'll survive
but that's right but but but for the
moment it has clearly caught the
public's imagination and even
conservative supporters overwhelmingly
think it's a good idea if i will his
trust i'd be quite worried
that unless she can trump that with a
policy that has even greater appeal she
will look as if she's lagging behind
labor on catching the public we had a
list trust supporter on the program
earlier on uh this morning and it didn't
look as though they were going to adopt
that certainly for now uh but who knows
she's been known to u-turn before who
would you vote for as tory leader was a
question that was asked as well um
that's right well
the ghosts of of of boris johnson has
been hanging over this conte contest so
when you go up last week polls tory
party members specifically specifically
supposing boris johnson were in the race
along with liz truss um and richie sunak
who would you vote for and if you look
at the figures you see that boris
johnson comes out miles ahead 46
for boris johnson uh that you see fully
that's what seller's remorse looks like
it does and there are signs from from
other polls that um both amongst party
members and perhaps now more importantly
as we move forward amongst the general
public this trust some of the shine is
becoming coming off this trusses
reputation um opinion poll on sunday
should amongst the public a couple of
weeks ago uh liz truss out ranked here
starburst best prime minister now
kiyosama has moved
into the lead over her that's why i'm
not quite so sure she'll get
a honeymoon period
of course in the long run
how she performs as prime minister will
determine it not my reputation after the
first few weeks but she's entering some
trickier waters than i think we all
expected a month or six years 18
inflation by january potentially um why
the public where does boris johnson sit
there
well now here's the thing that
when you
when you ask a standard question do you
approve or disapprove of boris johnson
as prime minister this is an opinion uh
survey over the weekend
boris johnson's ratings are pretty
terrible just a quarter of the public
think he's uh approve of his uh role as
prime minister well over half
disapprove
and here's the thing we saw that the
conservative support is down to 30
people take a point or two they've got
to get back up to well over 40 to win
the next election a lot of the people
who've deserted the conservatives are
people who feel let down by boris
johnson's personality and performance
and policies over the last couple of
years so if this trust is appealing to
the conservative activists she'll talk
up by johnson say how much of a fan she
is of his because party members love him
but he's trying to win back those lost
voters three four million lost voters
they're not people who like boris
johnson so if she goes all pro johnson
as prime minister i think it'll make it
harder for her to win back those three
or four million votes she needs always
great to see you thanks very much indeed
for joining us thank you